Guillain-Barre syndrome is an acute
rapidly Progressive autoimmune disorder
which affects the peripheral nervous
system it's also known as acute
inflammatory demyelinating
polyneuropathy or aidp
risk factors include
campylobacterogeneous infection viral
infection like Epstein-Barr virus or
cytomegalovirus or sometimes influenza
vaccine
visible symptoms involve swallowing
difficulty shortness of breath tingling
sensation
diagnosis involves
electromyography the conduction velocity
is measured and it is expected to be low
because the insulation in the nerve is
affected
treatment options include plasmaphoresis
and IVIG is the first line of treatment
then frequent monitoring of the
respiratory function because respiratory
collapse is one of the lead cause of
death then aggressive physical
rehabilitation and Physiotherapy and
Recovery might also take up to one year
watch the full video to know more